YUFEI ZHAO: So we've been
discussing graph limits
for a couple of lecturers now.
In the first lecture
on graph limits,
so two lectures ago, I stated
a number of main theorems.
And today, we will
prove these theorems
using some of the tools that
we developed last time, namely
the regularity lemma.
And also we proved this
Martingale convergence theorem,
which will also come in.
So let me recall what were the
three main theorems that we
stated at the end
of two lectures ago.
So one of them was the
equivalence of convergence.
On one hand, we defined
a notion of convergence
where we say that Wn
approaches W, by definition,
if the F densities converge.
We can say convergence even
without a limit in mind,
where we see a sequence
converges if all of these F
densities converge.
So the first main theorem
was that the two notions
of convergence are equivalent,
so one notion being convergence
in terms of F densities,
and the second notion
being convergence in the
sense of the cut norm, the cut
distance.
There was a second
term that tells us
that limits always exist.
If you have a
convergent sequence,
then you can represent
a limit by a graphon.
And the third statement
was about compactness
of the space of graphons.
So we're actually going
to prove these theorems
in reverse order.
We're going to start with the
compactness and work backwards.
So this is not how these
theorems were originally
proved, or not in that
order, but it will be helpful
for us to do this
by first considering
the compactness statement.
So remember we're
compactness says.
I start with this
space W tilda, which
is the space of graphons,
where I identify
graphons that have distance 0.
So if they have cut distance
0, then I refer to them
as the same point.
So this is now a metric space.
And the theorem is that
this space is compact.
So I think this, it's
a really nice theorem.
It's a beautiful theorem
that encapsulates
a lot of what we've been talking
about so far with similarities,
regularity, and what not, in
a qualitatively succinct way,
just that this space
of graphons is compact.
You may not have some intuition
about what the space looks
like at the moment,
but we'll see the proof
and hopefully that will
give you some more intuition
I first learned
about this theorem
when Laszlo Lovasz, who was one
of the pioneers in the subject,
when he came to
MIT to give a talk
when I was a graduate student.
And he said that
analysts thought
that they pretty much knew
all the naturally occurring
compact spaces out there.
So there are lots of spaces
that occur in analysis
and topology that are compact.
I mean, the first one you
learn in analysis undergraduate
is probably that an
interval is compact.
But there are also
many other spaces.
But this one here
doesn't seem to be
any of these classical
notions of compactness.
So it's, in some sense,
a new compact space.
So let's see how the proof goes.
Now, because we are
working in a metric space,
it suffices to show, due to the
equivalence between compactness
in the sense of
finite open covers
and sequential compactness
in the metric space,
so it suffices to show
sequential compactness,
that every sequence of graphons
has a convergent subsequence
with respect to this
cut metric and also will
produce a limit as a convergence
subsequence with a limit point.
So that's what we'll do.
I give you an arbitrary
sequence of graphons.
I want to construct by taking
subsequences a convergent
sequence.
And I will tell you
what that limit is.
So here is what we're going
to do, given this sequence.
As I hinted before, it has to
do with the regularity lemma.
So we're going to
apply the regularity
lemma in the above form,
which we did last time.
So apply the weak
regularity lemma,
which will tell us
that for each Wn,
there exists a partition, in
fact, a sequence of partitions,
each one refining the next.
So what's going to happen is,
I'm going to start with Wn
and starting with a trivial
partition, apply that lemma,
and obtain a
partition P sub n, 1.
And then starting
with that as my P0,
I'm going to apply regularity
lemma again and obtain
a refinement.
I will have this
sequence of partitions,
each one refining the next.
So all of these are
going to be partitions
of the 0, 1 interval.
And as I mentioned
last time, everything's
going to be measurable.
I'm not going to even
mention measurability.
Everything will
be measurable such
that they satisfy the
following conditions.
So the first one
is what I mentioned
earlier, is that you have
a sequence of refinements.
So each P sub n k plus 1 refines
the previous one for all n
and k.
And the second condition, as
given by the regularity lemma,
you get to control
the number of parts.
So I will say in the third part
what the error of approximation
is.
But you get to control
the number of parts.
So in particular, I can make
sure that this number here,
the number of parts in the k'th
partition depends only on k.
Now, you might
complain somewhat,
because the regularity lemma
only tells you an upper bound
on the number of parts.
But that's OK.
I can allow empty parts.
So now I make sure that the k'th
partition has exactly nk parts.
And the third one has to do
with the area of approximation.
OK, so suppose we write W sub
nk as the graphon obtained
by applying the
stepping operator.
So this is the averaging
operator on this partition,
corresponding to
the k'th partition.
I apply that partition, do a
stepping averaging operator
on the n'th graphon.
I get W sub nk.
The third condition is that the
k'th partition approximates--
it's a good approximation in the
cut norm up to error 1 over k.
So 1 over k is some
arbitrary sequence going to 0
as k goes to infinity.
So I obtained a
sequence of partitions,
so by applying the
regularity lemma
to each to each graphon
in the sequence.
Now, these graphons,
I mean, they
each have their own vertex set.
And so far, they're not
related to each other.
But to make the visualization
easier and also in order
to do the next
step in the proof,
I am going to do some
measure-preserving bisection So
think of this as permuting
the vertex labels.
So by replacing each
Wn by some W sub
n of phi, where phi is a
measure-preserving bisection,
we can assume that
all these partitions
are partitions into intervals.
So initially, you
might have a partition
into arbitrary measurable sets.
Well, what I can do is to push
over the first set to the left,
and so on, so do a
measure-preserving bisection
in a way so that I can maintain
that all the partitions are
visually chopping
up into intervals.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So at some point,
we need just one measure
for the projection, like
all of them be in k?
YUFEI ZHAO: OK, so
the question is,
it may be the case
that, for a given k,
I can do this
arrangement, but it's not
clear to you at the
moment why you can
do this uniformly for all k.
So one way to get
around this is, for now,
just think of for each given k.
And then you'll see at the end
that that's already enough.
OK, any more questions?
So now assume all of these
P sub nk's are intervals.
So in fact, what you said
may be a better way to go.
But to make our life
a little bit easier,
let's just assume for
now that you can do this.
OK, and what's
going to happen next
is some kind of a
diagonalization argument.
We're going to be
picking subsequences.
So I'm going to be
picking subsequences
so that they are
going to have very
nice convergence properties.
And so I'm going to
repeatedly throw out
a lot of the sequence.
So this is a
diagonalization argument.
And basically what
happens is that,
by passing two subsequences--
and we're going to do this
repeatedly, many times--
we can assume, first, that
the end points of P sub n1,
they converge as n
goes to infinity.
So each P sub n1 is some
partition of interval
into some fixed number of parts.
So by passing to
a subsequence, I
make sure that the division
points all converge.
And now, by passing
one more time,
so by passing to
subsequence one more time,
let's assume that also, W sub
n1 converges to some function,
some graphon u1, point-wise.
So initially, I
have these graphons.
Each one of them
is an m by n block.
They have various
division points.
By passing to a
subsequence, I assume
that the points of
division, they converge.
And now by passing to an
additional subsequence,
I can make sure the individual
values, they converge.
So as a result, W sub
n, 1 converges to W1--
converges to some graphon, u1,
point-wise, almost everywhere.
And we repeat for W
sub nk for each k.
So do this sequentially.
So we just did it
for k equals to 1.
Now do it for 2,
3, 4, and so on.
So this is a
diagonalization argument.
We do this countably many times.
At the end, what do we get?
We pass down to the
following subsequence.
And just to make my life
a bit more convenient,
instead of labeling the
indices of the subsequence,
I'm going to
relabel the sequence
so that it's still labeled
by 1, 2, 3, 4, and so on.
So we now pass to a
sequence W1, W2, W3,
and so on, such that if you
look at the first partition,
the first weak regularity
partition, they produce W1,1,
W2,1, W3,1, and so on.
And these guys, they
converge to u1, point-wise.
The second level, W2,1--
sorry, W1,2, W2,2, W3,2, they
converge to u2, point-wise,
and so on.
OK, so far so good?
Question?
AUDIENCE: Sorry,
earlier, why did that
converge to u1 point-wise?
YUFEI ZHAO: OK, so the
question is, why is this true?
Why is Wn,1 converge
to u1 point-wise?
Initially, it might not.
But what I'm saying is, you
can pass to a subsequence.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
YUFEI ZHAO: You can
pass to subsequence,
because there are only n1 parts.
So it's an n1 by m1
matrix of real numbers.
And so you only have finite
bounded many of them.
So you can pick a subsequence
so that they converge.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So how
do you make sure
that your subsequence is
not empty at the end-- like,
could you fix the first k?
YUFEI ZHAO: OK,
so you're asking,
if we do this slightly
not so carefully,
we might end up with
an empty sequence.
So this is why I say, you
have to do a diagonalization
argument.
Each step, you keep the
first term, the sequence,
so that you always
maintain some sequence.
You have to be slightly
careful with diagonalization.
Any more questions?
So by passing to
a subsequence, we
obtain this very nice sequence,
this nice subsequence,
such that each row corresponding
to each level of regularization
converges point-wise to some u.
So what do this u's look like?
So they are step graphons.
So let's explore the
structure of u a bit more.
OK, so since we have that each--
OK, so we have the property
that each partition
refines the previous partition.
And as a result, if you look
at the k plus 1'th stepping,
and I step it by the previous
partition in the sequence,
I should get back, I should
go back one in the sequence.
So this was this graphon
obtained by averaging over
the k'th partition.
And this is the graphon obtained
by averaging over the k'th plus
1st partition.
So if I go back one more, I
should go back in the sequence.
And since the u's are the
point-wise limit of these
W's, the same relationships
should also hold
for the u's, namely that u sub
k should equal to u sub k plus 1
if I step it with
Pk, where Pk is the--
so if you look at, all
these endpoints converge.
And these partitions,
they converge to P1.
So if you look at the partitions
that correspond to P1,1, P2,1,
and so on, I want these
partitions to converge to P1.
I want these partitions
to converge to P2.
So all these partitions, they
are partitions into intervals.
So I'm just saying,
if you look at where
the intervals, where the
divisions of intervals go,
they converge.
And then I'm calling the
limit partition P sub k.
And here we're using that P
sub k plus 1 refines P sub k,
because the same is
true for each end.
So in the limit, the same
must be true as well.
So you have this column of u's.
So let me draw you a picture of
what these u's could look like.
So here is an illustration
that may be helpful.
So what could these
u's look like?
Each one of them is represented
by values on the unit square.
And I write this
in matrix notation
so that inversion is
in the top left corner.
Well, maybe P1 is just
the trivial partition,
in which case u1 is going
to be a constant graphon.
Let's say it has value 0.5.
u2 came from u1 by
some partitioning.
And suppose just for the
sake of illustration,
there was only a
partitioning into two parts.
And OK, so it doesn't
have to be at the origin.
It doesn't have
to be at midpoint.
But just for illustration,
suppose the division
were at the midpoint.
Because u1 needs to have--
so this 0.5 value should
be the average value
in all of these four squares.
So for instance, the points
may be like 0.6, 0.6, 0.4, 0.4,
so for example.
And in u3, the partition,
the P3 partition-- so here
are the partition is P1.
The partition is P2.
There's two parts.
And suppose P3 three
now has four parts.
And again, for
illustration's sake,
suppose it is equally
dividing the interval
into four intervals.
It could be that now
each of these parts
is split up into four
different values in a way
that so you can obtain the
original numbers by averaging.
So that's one possible example.
Likewise, you can have
something like that.
Sorry, 4, 7-- so and I
should maintain symmetry
in this matrix.
And the last one, I'm just
going to be lazy and say
that it's still 0.4 throughout.
OK, so this is what the sequence
of u's are going to look like.
Each one of them splits up a box
in the previous u in such way
that the local averages, the
step averages are preserved.
Any questions so far?
All right, so now we
get to Martingales.
So I claim that this is
basically a Martingale.
So and suppose you let x, y
be a uniform point in the unit
square.
And consider this sequence.
So this is now a
random sequence,
because x, y are random.
I evaluate these u's on this
uniform random point, x, y.
So this is a random sequence.
And the main observation is
that this is a Martingale.
So remember the definition of
a Martingale from last time.
Martingale is one
where, if you look
at the value of u
sub k conditioned
on the previous
values, the expectation
is just the previous term.
And I claim this is
true for the sequence,
because of the way
we constructed it,
it's splitting up each box in
an averaging-preserving way.
A different way to see
this, and for those
of you who actually
know what the definition
of a random variable is in the
sense of probability theory,
is that you should view this
0, 1 squared as the probability
space, in which case u itself
is the random variable.
And this partitioning gives
you a filtration of the space.
It's a sequence of sigma
algebras dividing up the space
into finer and finer pieces.
So this is really
what a martingale is.
So we have a Martingale.
It's bounded because the
values take place in 0, 1.
So by the Martingale
convergence theorem,
which we proved last time,
we find that this sequence
must converge to some limit.
So this sequence of
Martingale converges,
which means, so if you think
about the interpretation
up there, so there
exists a u which
is a graphon such that uk
converges to u point-wise
almost everywhere as
k goes to infinity.
That's the limit.
So this is the limit.
And we're going to show
that it is indeed a limit.
But you see, this is a
construction of the limit,
where we took regularity,
got all these nice pieces,
found convergent
subsequences, and then
applied the
martingale convergence
theorem to produce
for us this candidate
for the limit, this u.
So now let us show that it is
indeed the limit that we're
looking for in the subsequence.
So again, I've tossed
out all the terms
which we removed in
passing to subsequences.
So in the remaining
subsequence, I
want to show that the
Wn's indeed converge to u.
And this is now a fairly
straightforward three epsilons
argument, the standard
analysis type argument.
But OK, so let's
carry it through.
So for every epsilon
bigger than 0,
suppose you pick a
sufficiently large k.
There exists a
And we make sure
k is large enough
such that u differs
from u sub k in l1 norm
by, at most, epsilon
over 3, because the uk's,
they converge to u
point-wise almost everywhere.
So we find this k.
So let's fix this k.
Then there exists an n0 such
that if you look at this u sub
k, it does not--
it is very close to
W sub nk for all n
large enough because of
what happened up there.
So we can now compute
the difference between--
in fact, let's do it this way.
So now let's compute
the difference,
the cut norm of the
difference between the term
in the sequence W sub n and u.
So by triangle
inequality, we have
that the following is true.
The cut norm is
upperbounded by the l1 norm.
Look at the definitions.
So I'm going to replace the
first couple of these cut norms
by l1 norms and leave
the last one in tact.
The first term, I claim is,
at most, epsilon over 3,
because up there.
The second term is going
to be at least epsilon
over 3, because over here.
And the third term is going
to be also, at most, epsilon
over 3, because well, from
the regularity approximation,
I know that it is,
at most, 1 over k.
And I chose k large enough
so that there is also,
at most, epsilon over 3.
Put everything together, we
find that these two are--
they different by, at most,
epsilon if n is large enough.
But now, since epsilon
can be arbitrarily small,
we find that you indeed have
convergence, as claimed.
And this finishes the
proof of compactness.
So there are a few components.
One is passing to--
so applying regularity,
passing to subsequences,
and obtaining this limit from
the regularity approximations,
these u's.
And then we observe that these
u's, they form a Martingale.
So we can apply the Martingale
convergence theorem to get
us a candidate for the limit.
And then the rest is
fairly straightforward,
because all the steps
are good approximations.
You put them together,
you prove the limit.
Any questions?
All right, so you may ask,
well, now we have compactness.
What is compactness good for?
So it may seem like a
somewhat abstract concept.
So in the second half
of today's lecture,
I want to show you how to use
this compactness claim combined
with the first definition of
compactness that you've seen,
namely every open cover
contains a finite sub cover,
and to use that to
prove many consequences
about the space of graphons.
And some things that we
had to work a bit hard at,
but they turn out to fall from
the compactness statement.
So let's take a quick break.
In the first part
of this lecture,
we proved that a space
of graphons is compact.
So now let me show you what
we can reap as consequences
from the compactness
result. So I
want to show you how
to apply compactness
and prove some consequences.
As I mentioned earlier,
the compactness result
is related to regularity.
And in fact, many of the
results I'm going to state,
you can prove maybe with some
more work using the regularity
lemma.
But I also want to show you
how to deduce them directly
from compactness.
In fact, we'll deduce
the regularity lemma
from compactness.
So these two ideas,
compactness and regularity,
they go hand-in-hand.
So first, more so as a warm
up, but as also an interesting
result, statement, an
interesting statement
on its own, so let me
prove the following.
So here is a statement that we
can deduce from compactness.
So for every epsilon,
there exists some number N
which depend only on epsilon,
such that for every W graphon,
there exists a graph
G with N vertices,
such that the cut
distance between G and W
is, at most, epsilon.
So think about what this says.
So for every epsilon,
there is some
bound N such that every
graphon-- so a graphon is
some real-value function, so
taking values between 0 and 1.
You can approximate
it in the distance
that we care about by a
graph with a bounded number
of vertices.
This is kind of like
regularity lemma.
If you are allowed edge
weights on this graph G,
then it immediately follows
from the weak regularity lemma
that we already proved.
And from that weak
regularity lemma
which allows you to get
some G with edge weights,
you can think
about how you might
turn an edge-weighted graph
into an unweighted graph.
So that can also be done.
But I want to show you a
completely different way
of proving this result that
follows from compactness.
And so I say it's a warm
up, because it's really
a warm up for the next
thing we're going to do.
This is an easier
example showing you
how to use compactness.
So the idea is, I have
this compact space.
I'm going to cover this space
by open sets, by open balls.
So the open balls are going
to be this B sub epsilon
G. So for each
graph, G, I'm going
to consider the set of graphons
that are within epsilon of G.
So this is you have
some topological space
or some metric space.
I have a point G. And I
look at its open ball.
This is the ball.
So I claim that these open
balls, they form an open cover,
of the space.
Where is that?
So I want to show every
point W is covered.
So this follows from the claim
that every W is the limit
of some sequence of graphs.
So we didn't technically
actually prove this claim.
I said that if you take W
random graphs, you get this.
So we didn't
technically prove that.
But OK, so it turns
out to be true.
There are easier ways
to establish it as well
by taking l1 approximations.
But the point is that, if
you use this claim here,
you do not get a bound on
the number of vertices.
It could be that for very
bizarre-looking W's, you
might require much more
number of vertices.
And a priori, you do not
know that it is bounded
as a function of epsilon.
But now we have this open cover.
So by compactness of
this space of graphons,
we can find an open cover
using a finite subset
of these graphs, so G1
to Gk, so a finite subset
to do an open cover.
And now we let N to be the
least-common multiple of all
of these vertex set sizes.
So all of these graphs,
they are within--
so for each of these
graphs, I can replace it
by a graph on
exactly N vertices.
There exists a graph Gi
prime of exactly N vertices,
such that they
represent the same point
in the space of graphons.
So why is this?
Think about the representation
of a graphon using
from a graph.
If I start with G and I blow
up each vertex into some k
vertices, then it turns out--
I mean, you should think
about why this is true.
But it's really not hard to
see if you draw the picture.
So remember, this black and
white picture, that actually,
they're the same point.
They are represented
by the same graphon.
OK, and that's it.
So we found these G's.
All of them have
exactly N vertices such
that their epsilon open
balls form an open cover
of the space of graphons.
So every graphon
can be approximated
by one of these graphs.
So you get that
from compactness.
The statement says, for every
epsilon, their exists an N.
So N is a function of
epsilon.l What's the function?
This proof doesn't tell
you anything about that.
So this proof gives
no information
about the dependence
of N on epsilon.
So in some sense, it's even
worse than some of the things
we've seen in the
earlier discussion
on Szemerédi's regularity
lemma where there were tower
or Wowzer-types.
Here there is no
information, because it comes
from a compactness statement.
So you just know there exists
a finite open cover, no bounds.
OK, any questions about
this warm-up application?
So it feels a bit magical.
So you have compactness.
And then you have all
of these consequences.
So now let me show you how
you can deduce the regularity
lemma itself from compactness.
In fact, in the proof
of the existence,
in the proof of compactness,
we only used weak regularity.
And now let me show you how
you can use the weak regularity
consequence of
namely compactness
to bootstrap itself
to strong regularity.
So we saw a version of strong
regularity in the earlier
chapter when we discussed
Szemerédi's regularity lemma.
So let me state it in a
somewhat different-looking form,
but that turns out to
be morally equivalent.
Suppose I have a
vector of epsilons.
So all of these are
positive real numbers.
The claim is that
there exists an M which
only depends on this vector
such that for every graphon W,
one can--
so every graphon W can be
written as the following,
decomposing the following way.
We write W as a sum
of a structured part,
a pseudo-random part,
and a small part,
where the structured part is
a step function with k parts,
but k is, at most, M,
this claimed bound M.
The pseudo-random part
has a very small cut norm,
so its cut norm, very
small, even compared
to the number of parts.
And finally, the small part has
l1 norm bounded by epsilon 1.
So that's the claim.
You can always--
there exists some
bound M in terms of
these error parameters
so that you have
this decomposition.
So we saw some version
of this earlier
when we discussed the spectral
proof of regularity lemma.
And I don't want to go into
details of how these two
things are related, but just
to comment that depending
on your choice of the
epsilon parameters,
it relates to some of
the different versions
of regularity lemma
that we've seen before.
So for example, if epsilon
k is roughly epsilon,
some fixed epsilon
over k squared,
then this is basically the
same as Szemerédi's regularity
lemma, whereas if all the
k's are the same epsilon,
then this is roughly the same
as the weak regularity lemma.
All right, so how
to prove this claim?
We're going to use
compactness again.
So first, there always
exists an l1 approximation
so that every W has some
step function u associated
to it such that the l1
distance between W and u
is, at most, epsilon 1.
So again, this is one of
these more measured theoretic
technicalities I don't
want to get into,
but so it's not hard to prove.
So roughly speaking,
you have some function.
You can approximate
it using steps.
So similar to what
we did just now,
if you just do that,
the number of steps
might not be a
function of epsilon,
so you might need much
more steps just doing
that if your W looks
more pathological.
So now what we're
going to do is consider
the following
function, k of W. And I
define it to be
the minimum k such
that there exists a k step
graphon u such that u you
minus W is, at most, epsilon 1.
So among all the step
function approximations,
pick one that has the
minimum number of steps
and call the number of
steps k of W. So now,
as before, we're
going to come up
with an open cover of
the space of graphons.
So the open cover is
going to be consisting
of the cut norm balls of--
actually, what notation
did I use over there?
So this is a ball
centered around W
with radius epsilon sub kW.
This is an open cover
of the space of graphons
as W ranges over all graphons.
So I'm literally looking
at every point in the space
and putting an open
ball around it.
So obviously, this
is an open cover.
And because of
compactness, there
exists a finite sub cover.
So there exists a
finite set, we write
curly s, of graphons such that
these balls, as I range over W
and curly s, they cover
the space of graphons.
Now the goal is,
given the W, I want
to approximate it in some way.
So having a finite set
of things to work with
allows us to do some
kind of approximations.
So thus, for every W graphon,
there exists a W prime in s
whose ball in that collection
covers the point W, such that W
is contained in this ball.
And OK, so given this W prime,
because of this definition
over here, so there
exists a u which
is a k step graphon
with k, at most,
the maximum over all such
possible number of steps,
such that W and W prime,
they are close in cut norm
because you have
this open cover.
And furthermore, W prime
is close to a graphon
with a small number of steps.
So suppose we now write W as u
plus W minus W prime and then
plus W prime minus u.
We find that this is the
decomposition that we
are looking for because the u--
so this is the
structural component--
has k steps, where k is less
than this quantity here.
And that quantity there is
just some function of epsilons.
So it's, at most, some
function of the epsilons.
It doesn't depend on the
specific choice of W.
The second term, this is
this pseudo-random piece,
because it's cut norm is
small, so what we have here.
Yeah, so this entire
thing should be subscript.
And finally, the third term
here is the small term,
because it's l1 norm is small.
So putting them together,
we get the regularity lemma.
So again, the proof gives
you no information whatsoever
about the bound M as a
function of the input
parameters, the epsilons.
So it turns out you can
use a different method
to get the bounds.
Namely, we actually more
or less did this proof
when we discussed regularity
lemma, the strong regularity
lemma.
So we did a different proof
where we iterated an energy
increment argument.
And that gave you some concrete
bounds, some bounds which
iterates on these epsilons.
But here is a different proof.
It gives you less
information, but it elegantly
uses this compactness feature
of the space of graphons.
Any questions?
OK, so we proved compactness.
So now let's go on to
the other two claims,
namely the existence
of the limit
and that equivalences
of convergence.
The existence of the
limit more or less
is a consequence of compactness.
So you have this sequence of
graphons, W1, W2, and so on.
And the claim is that, if
this sequence of F densities
converges for each
F, then there exists
some limit W such that all of
these sequences of F densities
converge to the limit density.
So that was the claim, so
nothing about cut norms
in at least as far as
the statement goes.
Well OK, from
compactness, we know
that you can produce always
a subsequential limit.
So by compactness or
sequential compactness,
there exists some limit
point which we call W.
And this W has
the property that,
for some subsequence,
the cut distance
from the subsequence
converges to W.
So for some subsequence n0
as ni going to infinity.
But now, by the counting lemma,
the sequence of F densities--
so the counting Lemma
tells you, if you
have cut distance going
to 0, then the F density
should also go to 0.
So indeed, that's
what we have here.
So this is so far just
for the subsequence.
But we assumed already
that the entire sequence
converges in respect
to every F densities.
So it must be the same limit.
And that finishes the
proof of convergence,
so proof of the
existence of the limit.
So we obtain this
limit from compactness.
Next, let's prove the
equivalence of convergence.
And this one is
somewhat trickier.
So what happens here
is that we would
like to show that these
two notions of convergence,
one having to do
with F densities
and another having to
do with cut distance,
that these two notions are
equivalent to each other.
So the goal here is to show that
this F density convergence is
equivalent to the statement that
W sub n is Cauchy with respect
to the cut distance.
All right, claim one of
the directions is easy.
Which direction is that?
So which direction is
the easy direction?
So which way, left,
going left, going right?
OK, so going left?
So I claim that this
is easy, because it
follows from counting lemma.
Counting lemma, remember the
spirit of the counting lemma,
at least qualitatively, is that
if you have two graphons that
are close in cut distance, then
they are close in F densities.
So if you have Cauchy with
respect to cut distance,
then they are Cauchy, and hence,
convergent in F densities.
And it's the other direction
that will require some work.
And this one is actually
genuinely tricky.
So and it's almost kind
of a miraculous statement,
that somehow if you only
knew the F densities--
so somebody gives you this
very large sequence of graphs
and only tells you that
the triangle densities,
the C4 densities, all of these
graph densities, they converge.
Somehow from these
small statistics,
you conclude that the
graphs globally look
very similar to each other.
That's actually,
if you think about,
this is an amazing statement.
OK, so let's see the proof.
The proof method
here is somewhat
representative of these
graph-limit-type arguments.
So it's worth paying attention
to see how this one goes.
So by compactness, if--
OK, we're going to set
up by contradiction.
If the sequence is
not Cauchy, then there
exists two limit points.
So there exists at least
two distinct limit points.
And call them u and
W, and such that--
so because you have two
separate limit points,
you must have that
this sequence,
at least along a subsequence
that converges to W,
converges in F densities
to W. So initially, this
is true along subsequence.
But the left-hand
side is convergent,
so this is true
along the sequence.
But u is also a limit point.
So the same is true for u.
And therefore, the F density in
W must equal to the F density
in u for all F.
So we would be done if we can
prove that the F densities,
the collection of all
these F densities,
they determine the graphon.
And that's indeed the case.
And so this is the next claim.
So it's what I
will call a moment
lemma, is that if u and W
are graphons such that the F
densities agree for all F,
then the cut distance between u
and W is equal to 0.
Somehow the local statistics
tells you globally
that these two graphons
must agree with each other.
Does anyone know why I
call it a moment lemma?
There is something else which
this should remind you of.
So there are some classical
results in probability that
tells you, if you have two
probability distributions,
both, assume are nice enough,
then if they have the same
k'th moment for every k, so
first moment, second moment,
third moment, if all
the moments agree,
that these two probability
distributions should agree.
And this is some
graphical version of that.
So instead of looking at the
probability distribution,
we're looking at graphons,
which are two-dimensional.
These are
two-dimensional objects.
And this moments lemma tells you
that in these two-dimensional,
in the corresponding
two-dimensional moments, namely
these F moments,
if they agree, then
the two graphons must agree.
So it's the analog of
the probability theory
statement about moments.
The proof is actually
somewhat tricky.
So I'm only going to
give you a sketch.
And the key here is to consider
the W random graph, which
we saw last lecture.
So this is W random
graph with k vertices
sampled using the graphon W.
So a key observation
here is that,
for every F, the probability
that the sampled W
random graph agrees with F--
and here, there is a
bit of a technicality.
I want them to agree
as labeled graphs.
So the vertices of W are a
priori labeled 1 through k.
And this kW random graph
is generated with vertices
labeled 1 through k.
They agree with some
probability that is completely
determined by the F densities.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Is k the
number of vertices of F?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so k is
the number of vertices of F.
And the specific formula
is not so important.
Let me just write it down.
But the point is that, if you
know all the F densities, then
you have all the information
about the distribution
of this W random graph.
And the way you can calculate
the actual probability
is via an inclusion exclusion.
And the reason we have to
do this inclusion exclusion
is just because this
is more like counting
induced subgraphs.
And this is counting
actual subgraphs.
So there is an extra step.
But the point is that, if you
knew this data, the moment's
data then you immediately
know the distribution of the W
random graphs.
OK, so if I have two graphons
for which I know that their F
densities agree,
then I should be
able to conclude that
the corresponding W
random graphs also have the same
distribution, in particular,
this, the W random graph
and the u random graph
have the same distribution.
I am going to create a
variant of the W random graph
which is something
called an H random graph.
It's kind of like
the W random graph
except I forget
the very last step.
So I only keep a weighted--
think of it as, so think this
is an edge-weighted graph where
you sample x1 through xk
uniformly between 0 and 1.
And I put edge weight between
i and j to be W of xi xj.
So the difference between this
H version and the G version
is that the G
version is obtained
by turning this weight
into an actual edge
with that probability, but
if I don't do the last step,
I obtain this
intermediate object.
So the following are true.
And this is where I'm
going to skip the proofs.
If I look at this H random
graph and the G random graph,
they are very close
in cut distance.
You can think of
this as the claim
that G and P is very close
to G in cut distance.
So they are very
close in cut distance.
As k going to infinity
with probability 1--
so now I'm going
to do the proof.
But it's some kind of a
concentration argument.
And the second claim is that
the H random graph is actually
very close to the original
graphon W, as well.
This is also little l1 in
distance as k goes to infinity.
So this one is,
again, not so obvious.
But it's easier
in the case when W
itself is a step function,
in which case, the produced
H is almost the same as W,
except the boundaries are
slightly shifted, perhaps.
And so you first approximate
W by a step function,
and prove this up to an
epsilon approximation,
and then let the
steps go to infinity.
So if you have these
two claims, so then
we see that this one here is
identically distributed as ku.
So it should follow that the
corresponding H random graph
for u, if you place the same
inequalities by the u versions,
it should also be true.
So because these two are
the same distribution,
if you follow this
chain, you obtain
that the cut distance between
u and w is equal to 0.
I want to close by
mentioning, in some sense--
so here, you have two graphons
that have exactly the same F
moments.
But what if I give you two
graphons which have very
similar moments to each other?
Can you conclude
that the two graphons
are close to each other?
And that will be some kind
of an inverse counting lemma.
And in fact, it does
follow as a corollary.
And the statement is
that, for every epsilon,
there exists k and eta such that
if the two graphons u and W are
such that the F densities do
not differ by more than eta
for every F on, at
most, k vertices,
then the cut distance between
u and W is, at most, epsilon.
So the counting lemma tells you,
if the cut distance is small,
then all the F moments
are close to each other.
And the inverse tells
you this converse.
So it tells you this, if
you have similar F moments,
up to a certain point,
then this is small.
You can deduce the
inverse counting lemma
from the moments lemma
via a compactness argument
similar to the one that
we did in class today.
And I want to give you a chance
to practice with that argument.
So this will be on the
homework, for the next homework.
I'll give you some
practice with using
these compactness arguments.
But you see, just with the
other compactness statements,
it doesn't tell you anything
about the k and the epsilon
as a function of--
the k and eta as a
function of epsilon.
So there are other proofs that
gives you concrete bounds,
but this proof here
is much simpler
if you assume the corresponding
results about compactness.
And finally, I want to mention
that in the moments lemma,
in order to deduce that
u and w have the same--
that they are basically
the same graphon,
we need to consider F
moments for all F's.
So you might ask,
could it be the case
that we only need some
finite set of F's to deduce--
to recover the graphon?
Is it the case that
you can recover W
from only a finite
number of F moments?
And this is, it's actually
a very interesting problem
for which we already
saw one instance.
Namely, when we discussed
quasi-random graphs,
we saw that if you know
that the k2 moment is p
and also the C4 moment
is p to the 4, then
we can deduce that
the graphon must
be the constant graphon, p.
OK, so we didn't do
it in this language,
but that's what the proof does.
And likewise, you can use this
to deduce a qualitative version
where you have an extra slack
and an extra slack over here.
So you might ask, except
for the constant graphons,
are there other graphons
for which you can similarly
deduce--
recover this graphon from just
a finite amount of moments data?
And such graphons are
known as finitely forcible.
So finitely forcible
graphons W such
that a finite number of
moments can uniquely recover--
can uniquely identify
this graphon, W.
And a very interesting
question is,
what is the set of all
finitely forcible graphons?
And it turns out, this
is not at all obvious.
And let me just give you some
examples, highly non-trivial,
that turned out to
be finitely forcible.
For example, anything
which is a step graphon
is finitely forcible.
The half graphon
which corresponds
to the limit of a
sequence of half graphs
is finitely forcible.
I mean, already, I think
neither of these two examples
are easy at all.
And this example here
can be generalized where
you have any polynomial curve.
I think this has to be--
so if it's a polynomial curve,
it's also finitely forcible.
But turns out finitely
forcible graphons
can get quite complicated.
And there is still rather quite
a bit of mystery around them.
OK, so next time, I want to
discuss some inequalities that
come out of--
you can state between
different F densities.
OK, great.
That's all for today.